so I just I watched last night finally
that Peter Jackson documentary they
shall not grow old and it is just
stunning it remarkable it's an
achievement you can't say that about
very many films but it really is an
achievement it's like it's the closest
thing you'll ever experience to going in
a time machine presumably unless someone
actually invents one so if you're not
familiar the documentary is about world
war 1 and it follows a group of British
soldiers as they starting at home and
then they enlist and go to basic and
then and then hit the trenches and the
entire film consists of there's no
narration it consists of interviews with
veterans of the war obviously interviews
that were conducted decades ago and then
also archival footage but this is you
know 100 years ago they didn't have you
couldn't record sound or color
everything was sped up grainy black and
white silent and so what Jackson and his
team did was they they colorized it they
slowed it down and then they put sound
with it including hiring lip readers to
just to tell what these men were saying
and then they hired voice actors to dub
the original dialogue back in and the
effect is it's like you're watching
I mean it's you're watching actual
footage from a hundred years ago but
it's like you're watching a Hollywood
film and except it's real and so it's
just staggering
I demand that you go watch it alright I
demand it alright I won't take no for an
answer
so a lot of a lot to talk about today
but before we get going I need to tell
you about hair club
listen confidence is important it's one
of the most important things you need
you need confidence in life to do
anything it's like they say in skydiving
you don't need the parachute all you
need is confidence which is actually
really bad if I guess they don't say
that about about skydiving but it is
important in everything else in life or
confidence is key and sometimes just one
it'll change that you make can make all
the difference in terms of confidence
and hair club knows this and they're
inviting you to become part of the hair
club family and and just to see how
getting the most out of your hair can
make such a huge difference in your life
here's the thing the people at hair club
they understand the emotions that you
feel when you start losing your hair and
they know all the questions that you're
asking when you start when you start
losing it your hair I mean not your mind
and so hair club is the leader in total
hair solutions with a legacy of success
for over 40 years
whether you're looking to revitalize the
growth of your own hair or to learn more
about the latest proven methods for hair
replacement or restoration hair clubs
professionally trained stylist hair
health experts and consultants will
craft a personalized solution to ensure
you feel your best and you get the most
out of your hair so you can just see for
yourself how powerful great hair can be
it's powerful not just because it looks
nice but because of the emotional
benefits you get from being able to
reclaim your look reclaim yourself
basically so go to hair club.com slash
walsh
today for a free hair analysis and a
free take home hair kit all valued at
over $300 but that's for free hair club
comm slash walsh for a free hair
analysis and free hair kit hair club
comm slash walsh alright
big news out of academia today fifty
very rich people have been charged in a
bribery scheme wherein they paid paid to
have their children admitted into
college basically which everyone pays to
have their kids admitted in the college
but but they paid in illegal ways they
paid under false pretenses
these parents paid an admissions
consultant who then bribed
administrators and coaches and testing
officials and so on to get the kids in
they had their kids admitted into school
in various different ways by claiming
that they were going to join for
instance the crew team even if the kids
had no experience in the sport and we're
not actually planning
playing let me just I'll read a bit from
the AP article on this it says at least
nine athletic Coaches and thirty-three
parents many of them prominent in law
finance or business were among those
charged dozens including including
Huffman actress were arrested by midday
the coaches worked at such schools as
Yale Stanford Georgetown Wake Forest
University of Texas University of
Southern California and the University
of California Los Angeles
a former Yale soccer coach pleaded
guilty and helped build the case against
others prosecutors said parents paid
admissions consultants from 2011 through
last month to bribe coaches and
administrators to falsely make their
children look like star athletes to
boost their chances of getting into
college the consultant also hired
ringers to take college entrance exams
for the students and paid off insiders
at testing centers to alter students
scores parents spent anywhere from two
hundred thousand to six point five
million dollars to guarantee their
children's of mission mission officials
said the US attorney and ruling said for
every student admitted through fraud and
honest and genuinely talented student
was rejected several defendants
including Felicity Huffman the actress
were charged with conspiracy to commit
fraud punishable by up to 20 years in
prison and the the case is ongoing other
parents charged were Gordon Kaplan of
Greenwich Connecticut co-chairman of an
international law firm based in New York
Jane Buckingham CEO of a boutique
marketing company Gregory Abbott founder
and chairman of a packaging company
manual Henriques CEO of a finance
company so a bunch of really rich people
to sum it up we're doing this now this
is an interesting item this is an
interesting news story because in a way
it brings the left and the right
together it's a very rare news story
where both sides at least are furious
about it and are outspoken about it and
care about it
right because it seems like with it with
most new stories these days you can't
even get an agreement on the two sides
that this issue is important but this is
one where both sides agree and that's
largely because it gives both sides an
opportunity to go on their favorite
tangents so for the left this is about
privilege they're talking about well
this is a proof of privileges is what
happens when you have privilege and for
the right it's about corruption in
academia now both sides are right
although the right is more right about
this
as far as privilege yeah this this is
indeed about about privilege but but
it's the privilege of wealth not race
manual Henriques was one of the people
charged as I mentioned that doesn't
sound like the name of a white guy I
could be wrong but it doesn't but it
doesn't doesn't sound like it so this is
just about money that's all this is
about if you're rich you buy your way in
the people getting bribed you know they
don't care what race you are the only
color they care about is green if you
have the money then you you can do it
that's all that matters
this is a case actually that I think
undermines the left's general narrative
about privilege because it shows that
money talks and that's how privilege
works it's not race it's just money if
you're rich then you can do what you
want which we already knew that
right now I don't want to get off on my
own irrelevant rant here but this is
what frustrates me about the left's
whole narrative about privilege because
we could have a worthwhile discussion
about privilege and about what it means
and and all that kind of stuff and about
the ways that sometimes wealthy people
are able to game the system and so on I
mean that's that's a worthwhile thing to
talk about but we have to let go of the
idea that it's automatically tied to
race because it isn't a black kid in the
inner city in Baltimore
has no privilege to speak of we know
that but I can tell you this a white kid
growing up in a in a trailer park and in
a meth infested trailer park in Eastern
Kentucky he doesn't have any privilege
either and there's a very striking clue
that the kid in the trailer park has no
privilege you know how you know he has
no privilege aside from the fact that he
has no money and there's drugs all
around and his dad's gone and it's been
his mother's addicted to drugs aside
from that it's it's the fact that
society would call him and his family
and his entire community white trash we
literally call these people garbage and
it's okay to do that nobody bats an eye
nobody no one bats an eye at the at the
phrase white trash right now if you were
to put any other race in front of the
word trash that would be unspeakable
racism but with white people you could
say hey yeah white trash but think about
that phrase right white trash we're
calling them garbage simply because of
where they live and how much money they
have or don't have and yet while we call
them garbage we still say that they are
the the beneficiaries of some kind of
invisible privilege well you know I
don't know what kind of privilege there
is in being considered garbage by
society but that is privileged that I
certainly wouldn't want myself so if
society sees you as actual trash and
calls you that then you ain't got
privilege we just put it that way that's
a good rule of thumb but I think the
problem is that the people who talk
about white privilege have simply never
seen white poverty they don't know what
it looks like they've never seen a
trailer park you know and they haven't
seen the hopeless third world conditions
that some white kids grow up in and they
assume that all white families live in
single-family homes in the suburbs and
that's just simply not
so anyway that this scandal shows the
true nature of privilege which as I said
is about is about money not about race
and even more so though it shows the
true nature of modern academia
it shows what I've been saying all along
which is that higher education has
turned into a massive scam academia is
intellectually and morally corrupt from
top to bottom that's the fact academia
is a business and they are in the
business of making money as any
businesses that's what they care about
not educating your kids but making money
off of your kids of course you're going
to have problem
once the
the art of Education becomes a
billion-dollar business when that
happens you're going to have corruption
and scandal and all of this stuff and
that's just there's no way around it and
that's where we are to where we've been
for a long time and we can see that fact
evidenced not just by the manner in
which these kids got into these schools
by but but also by what happened once
they got in namely nothing happened
nothing unusual I mean these kids
apparently they they they just went
along and did fine you're not reading
from what I've read these kids didn't
fail out they're not gonna flunk out of
school because that would defeat the
whole purpose so so think about that for
a second they lied their way in or at
least their parents lied for them I
think it's very likely that these kids
didn't had no idea that they were that
their parents were doing that so and I
do feel badly for these kids as well
that although they're rich and
privileged at the same time they're
probably now just now discovering that
that's how they got into school and they
thought that they earn their way in and
apparently know so they got in without
any qualification and the system if it's
if it's really about education and if
it's really about a sort of rigorous
academic program then it should be kind
of it should it should be able to filter
out kids like that it should be able to
guard itself against this kind of thing
because if you got in without the
academic qualifications then you should
fail out you shouldn't be able to make
it but but these kids got in and they
did fine which shows you that it's not
about rigorous academic study it's just
a place where you go and you coast
through and you get your degree and you
do all this for social status and for
credentials not for actual intellectual
enrichment College is
just one big credentialing credential a
credentialing there we go I can't even
say the word mechanism it's a mechanism
for giving kids credentials and social
status and that's what it is
Lori Loughlin Aunt Becky from full house
was indicted as well in this scandal and
she allegedly paid several hundred
thousand dollars to get her kids into
college one of those kids her daughter
got into I think it was USC this way and
that daughter then proceeded to spend
her time at college becoming apparently
a YouTube star she has a YouTube channel
where she tries on makeup and stuff and
it's she's got like two million
subscribers that watch her try on
clothes and different and makeup and
that sort of thing which which by the
way has given me the idea that maybe I
should start maybe I need to start
wearing makeup on this show and and
finally it'll really take off the
numbers will skyrocket but let me show
you just because it's I think it's it
kind of demonstrates what I'm talking
about let me show you a little clip of
this girl this is Laurie law aunt
Becky's daughter let me show you a
little clip of this girl recording one
of her YouTube videos I don't know how
much of school I'm gonna attend but I'm
gonna go in and talk to my Dean's and
everyone and hope that I can try and
balance it all but I do want the
experience of like gamedays partying I
don't really care about school as you
guys okay so she she's not sure if she's
gonna go to classes at all she doesn't
really like school she's thinking about
maybe she'll go to class maybe she won't
but she wants the experience of of like
game day and parties and stuff that's
what she says and listen I'm I'm not
trying to single her out for that
attitude because that is precisely the
attitude that many probably most kids
have when they go to college for them
for kids this is the way it works for
the kids college is about the experience
of partying that's what the kids can but
they they want the experience for their
parents it's about social status
credentials for the school
administrators it's about money for many
of the professors it's about ideological
indoctrination the one thing that we're
missing here with all these groups is an
actual concern for education itself few
people in any of these groups are
worried about education they all have
their different things that they're
worried about and that they want out of
it but education has little to do with
it and that's why it's perfectly
possible even commonplace forgets kids
to go to college and graduate with a
degree and learn absolutely nothing the
whole time why do you think why is it so
easy for for anyone with a YouTube
channel and a camera and a microphone to
go to pretty much any college campus and
do one of those man on the street
interview things where they where they
you know quiz random people with these
very easy questions and then no one
knows the answers and you know then they
can prove how stupid everybody is well
you see a million of those things on
YouTube and so often they're on college
campuses and why is it so easy to do
that if you want to get a million hits
on YouTube you know that all you need to
do is is get like a third grade civics
exam and you grab your camera and a
microphone and go to any college campus
and ask these kids any of these
questions and and people won't be able
to answer it it shouldn't be that easy
it shouldn't be that easy to find
absolute clueless morons on a college
campus but you can because you don't
need to be intelligent to get in you
don't need to be hard-working and you
don't need to be intelligent or
hard-working to graduate that's the
reality so what when are we going to
wake up to this when are we gonna as
I've said it a million times but when
are we going to stop playing this game
and realize that academia has become a
scam it's corrupt and so the only way to
change anything is
like we've been talking about money
talks right so if we stop giving these
people our money and more importantly if
we stop feeding our children into this
system then maybe there will be some
changes but if we're not willing to do
that if we're not willing to make that
change then it's just gonna go on like
this and it's never gonna get any better
all right what else sigh let's see there
was this headline on The Daily wire
mothers team up to create a porn film
they want their children to watch yeah
I'm not gonna even go there it's just
too disturbing all right here's one
here's one other thing I talked
yesterday about the case of the man
who's suing an abortion clinic because
his child was aborted against his wishes
and I wanted to go back to that for a
second to highlight a point an important
point the whole reason why this man had
to sue in the first place is that his
girlfriend was able to kill his child
without his consent
right and so now he's suing and he's so
far been able to go forward suing in the
in the place of of the aborted child and
but the reason it got to this point is
that as we talked about yesterday
men have no reproductive rights we hear
about this thing of reproductive rights
and this is a whole category of Rights
that men don't have now think about that
for a second human reproduction as much
as the left would like to change this
fact it still remains the fact that in
every case of human reproduction in
human history
in the billions of instances of human
reproduction it has always involved a
man and a woman in every single case so
men are just as essential to the
reproductive act as our women
yet we have invented this whole category
that we call reproductive rights and men
don't have any can you think of one
reproductive right that a man has he has
none a whole category of Rights that men
are excluded from they have no rights as
parents until the child is born and even
after the child is born the father still
are treated by the law as essentially
expendable and replaceable we all know
how it goes in family court it's it's it
is a lot a lot easier for in case of a
divorce or something it's a lot easier
for the woman to be awarded custody of
the children than it is for the for the
man and there are just a million
examples of this and this is the way it
goes which only affirms yet again a an
important point which is that women in
the United States do not suffer any form
of systematic legal oppression and that
only now that might sound like a bold
statement oh it only sounds like a bold
statement if you've been brainwashed by
feminist rhetoric and you might kind of
instinctively viscerally be taken aback
by that but but to anyone else it's
that's incredibly obvious that you
cannot provide one example of systematic
legal inequalities that women are
subjected to our women suffer from you
cannot think come up with an example of
of legal inequality for women now I
already gave you there there are several
examples I already gave you one of a
legal inequalities where men are on the
losing end of it where men are legally
unequal to women so I've given you one
example of that it's a pretty profound
example where women
have the legal right to murder a man's
child so that's one except but you can't
come up with one example in the other
night in fact the the only example and I
put this challenge out on Twitter last
night and there were a lot of people
react they do it so well that's crazy
but nobody could come up with an example
except the only example that one person
came up with was um was that well men
are allowed to to walk around topless
and women can't so okay now in many
places in the country that's not the
case anymore
and in fact in you know in most places
you go everyone is expected to keep
their shirts on but it is true that
there are some you know counties and in
towns where especially on if you go to
the beach or something men cannot have
their shirts out and women are supposed
to wear shirt so far okay so there you
go if that's that's the one thing left
right that's the one example of legal
inequalities that women are expected to
keep their shirts on in in many places
still in America so you got that but
that is just so incredibly outweighed by
the fact that yes well women supposed to
keep their shirts on legally but they
also have the power to kill human beings
so I think the thing that outweighs it
so much that it doesn't even count still
the fact remains that at the very least
we would have to agree that the deck is
stacked heavily in favor of women didn't
used to be that way of course it was was
only a hundred years ago that women
couldn't vote but that has all changed
and it has been changed for a long time
now which is why the feminist movement
is utterly completely worthless and I
think it's a
crucial for us to understand this
because you still hear sometimes from
conservatives who say that say well you
know yeah the the feminist movement now
has gone off the rails and everything
but they're still fighting for something
important and so we need to reclaim
feminism or whatever no we don't need to
reclaim it it is a worthless movement
because it has nothing left to fight for
and this is just one of the it's it's so
true that it's become a cliche that that
after a a movement has achieved what
it's set out to achieve if it sticks
around if it doesn't go away if it
sticks around then it will become right
it becomes a racket it becomes a scam
and that's what's happened with feminism
100 years ago that we're fighting for
real legal equality now they have it and
now there's just nothing there's nothing
left and so they're marching around with
genitalia on their head and they're
doing this an ad and and maybe they make
a big deal out of something like oh men
are allowed to have their shirts off you
know that kind of thing because there's
got nothing I know other battles left to
fight which is why the feminist movement
I think from from rational people the
feminist movement at this point is owed
nothing but content and primarily
because when I say it's worthless it's
worse it's much worse than worthless
because actually what is the primary
thing that the feminist movement now
fights for and that is to protect its
right to kill human beings which makes
it worse than worthless it is actually
an evil movement finally this is very
important I want you to watch something
MIT Romney had a birthday yesterday so
happy birthday to Mitt Romney I don't
know how old he turned and there is
footage from his birthday celebration
that has confused
used and disturb the nation and so first
of all now let's leave aside the fact
that he's eating a Twinkie cake Twinkies
are of course completely revolting
they're like moldy sponges injected with
off-brand ready-whip or something but
the thing that most people are focusing
on is the fact that he that he the way
that he blew out the candles
he took each candle off the cake right
and he blew it out individually which
I've never seen anyone do that before
and he's being attacked across the
nation for this for the way that he blew
out the candles I saw him on Twitter
someone said that he he blows out
candles like a serial killer now maybe
he does I I'm not I mean I don't really
know how serial killers typically deal
with birthday candles maybe that's how
they do it but I will say this serial
killer or not I think that Mitt Romney
by blowing the candles out that way has
proven that he is a visionary and a
humanitarian it is about time that
people
blowing their rancid disgusting spittle
all over perfectly good cakes why has it
is the year 2019 and we are still doing
this think about the whole concept of
blowing on a pastry item before you
share it with a whole group of people
you're saying like hang on a second I'm
going to distribute some of my mouth
particles on this cake before here I put
some extra flu virus on this slice of
cake Gary yeah have some of this um I
have some of that this is how we this
this is how you spread disease this this
is how people get the plague it is
through this kind of thing how would you
react if you were going to Outback
Steakhouse and your your waiter brought
out your steak and before he handed it
to you he said hold on a second it's
disgusting off if it's in if it's the
worst with kids have you ever been to a
you ever seen like a three-year-old
blow out candles on a cake my son when
he blows out candles like cake he
essentially just hocks a loogie on the
cake that's what he does he puts out the
candles by spitting on it
and people still eat the cake like no
one's bothered by this you ever been to
a toddler's birthday party and the worst
thing there is that all the kids want to
blow out the candles so it ends up being
this free-for-all and all the kids are
blowing their mucus they're basically
frosting the cake with their mucus and
then everyone eats it and no one is dis
time the only one everyone is like oh
yeah give me some of that I'm standing
in the back like oh my so of course
every birthday party now I bring a CSI
kit with a blacklight and I take it out
and I you know first hey everyone backup
I inspect the cake and I say give me
that and I notice there's one little
corner without any mucus give me that
corner right there so that's what I do
and sometimes I'll bring if that's not
good enough I also bring a backup cake
that I keep in the trunk
worst comes to worst I'll go out and eat
the cake in the trunk because of course
I'm not gonna give up the cake I'm not
crazy I'm just saying I'm not gonna eat
someone's spit so you know what maybe
around the is setting an example for all
of us to follow and I want you to think
about this everyone says well you got to
blow out all the candles and one breath
for good luck or whatever no well it
might be good luck for you okay and
that's fine but you just gave everybody
else bronchitis so congratulations you
sociopath happy birthday all right um
let's check some emails Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com some interesting ones today
will go first to Joel who says hi Matt
really enjoy the show I was recently in
a discussion with someone about the
accuracy of the Bible and they made a
point that I did I answer this one
yesterday no I don't think I did they
made a point of that I thought I'd like
your opinion on he said that the Bible
stories we were talking specifically
about the Gospels were transmitted
orally before they were written down he
said that the transmission of stories
orally is like the telephone game the
story changes over time there's no way
for us to know if the story written down
in the Gospels is the same as the first
time it was told how would you respond
to that thank you for the question
Joel this is a pretty common meme common
argument from from often from atheists
Bart Ehrman the Atheist New Testament
scholar uses this analogy a lot and I'm
that's that probably might be where your
atheist friend got it
Erman says that that the stories about
Jesus were told they were passed down
through through spoken word for decades
and they necessarily would have changed
with the telling much like the telephone
game now I'm kind of surprised when
smart guys like Arman used this analogy
of the telephone game because it's it's
completely without basis and I'll
explain why but first we have to we have
to say that you know we can't the easy
answer for Christians is to say well no
because first of all the Gospels were
written by eyewitnesses and second they
had the Holy Spirit telling them what
happened
helping to keep it accurate right and so
that's that's the easy answer that
probably most Christians would go with
and it's true well two of the Gospels
were written by eyewitnesses the other
two Mark and Luke were or not but it's
also true that we don't know exactly
what the process of inspiration looked
like or what it consisted of and it's
probably not as straightforward as God
literally speaking the words audibly
into the ears of you know Matthew Mark
Luke and John and then them sort of just
being typists for god of transcribing
what he said
it seems that inspiration worked through
a more human process which is not
surprising because that's that's the way
that God in our own experience in life
right that's how God seems to always
work is through is through is through a
human process and what I mean is that if
you read the Gospels side by side
especially if you read a parallel gospel
translation which I recommend going out
and getting one of those very
interesting where you it gives you that
usually be the Synoptics gives you each
passage you know side by side with all
with the other three and you see rather
inescapably that one of these Gospels
probably mark was written first and the
others used it as a source in fact Luke
even says in the preamble to his gospel
that he that he used sources he doesn't
say use Mark's Gospel but but he does
say that he interviewed people and he
you know collected all the best
information and that's how he's writing
his gospel so we already know that
that's how its it says it right there in
the text and we know because we know
that because there there are whole
sections of Matthew and Mark and Luke
that are verbatim the same and then
there
sections that are very different which
is what you would expect if Matthew was
using mark and then also using other
sources and also using his own
recollections so that's what Matthew
looks exactly as you would expect it to
look if that's if that was the process
for writing the Gospel of Matthew with
the Holy Spirit guiding the process but
not in such a way as to make Matthew
basically a puppet who almost against
his will is just moving his hand across
the papyrus right so the point is it's
perfectly possible even likely that the
Gospel writers especially mark and Luke
did use for some of their stories oral
tradition and you know to me that seems
almost certain that that's part of what
happened but this doesn't mean that the
oral tradition was changed or mutated
and the telephone game is an absurd
comparison and I think the people who
use this comparison at least the
scholarly educated ones who use it they
know that it's a bad comparison because
they know that the whole point of the
telephone game is to change the message
right the rules of the game are set in
such a way as to make it so that the
message changes it wouldn't the game
wouldn't be any fun if if you
transmitted the message accurately in
fact I will fully admit that I would
admit it at this at the time but when I
was a kid we played the telephone game
when the message got to me I would
intentionally change it to make it
funnier and so I would all basically no
matter what any matter what the message
was I would always hear something
involving poop and then I would transmit
that because everything is funnier when
you put poop into it obviously so that's
the way the telephone game works oral
tradition especially in an oral culture
does not work that way it's not like
you're only allowed to say it once and
you have to whisper it to one person and
then they could only whisper - that's
not the way it works it would be there
were
you know it was done in such a way as to
try to maximize accuracy not minimize it
and you tried not to change the story
and also most of historians who've
looked at this know that people in these
oral you know these cultures of oral
tradition they they had methods they had
you know strategies for how they
memorize these things and they also just
had better memories for it than we do we
don't have to have great memories
because we have everything written down
because we're a literate culture so
everything is written down so you don't
need to remember it but that wasn't the
way it was for them so if you wanted to
know your history you you had to
remember it it was something like you
know like 98% of the people back in that
time and in that part of the world
couldn't couldn't read and write so if
they wanted to know anything and and be
informed about their own culture and
their own history they had to remember
it so you know I just think that that
comparison is is a little ridiculous
let's see from Jerry says Matt I'm sorry
but I have to tell you that your show is
definitely caps-lock
the worst show on The Daily wire I don't
know how you still have a job it's a
mystery to both of us Jerry I don't know
how either I honestly if you can even
call this a job in which it really it
isn't from Aaron says hello I was
listening to your show today and it
reminded me once again that I have an
amazing husband you were discussing the
selfishness of a man that wrote that he
regretted having his son I already knew
that my husband was awesome but this
discussion brought it to the front of my
thoughts when I met my husband I was a
single mom of three kids shortly after
he and I were married we had a set of
twins my husband went from zero kids to
five in less than a year that you know I
was bragging about going from zero kids
to two with our twins but that's I can't
compete with that even though three of
the kids are not biologically hits he
his he supports them spiritually
emotionally and financially as if they
were his own he and I now have six
children and feel very blessed I think
sometimes women are busy mothering and
taking our husbands for granted at least
I know I'm guilty of this thing
for all you do my husband and I are big
fans I would appreciate a shout out to
my awesome husband and father of my
children his name is Monty shoutout to
to Monty I think that's great
real man you've found yourself there
Aaron and I also think it's great that
you're showing gratitude to your husband
this is I've talked about it before but
I think this is certainly one of the top
three most important things in a
marriage is is gratitude from both
parties towards the other and just
recognizing their contributions as you
said we get lost in the in the day to
day stuff and it's very easy to lose
sight of what the other person is doing
so I think it's great that you're
remembering that and acknowledging it
this is from Heath he says today my
friend brought up a pretty good topic on
if Christians are allowed to kill during
wartime this came up when we were
talking about the bombs dropped in Japan
and how many civilians died
I don't believe citizens should die
during war but I also don't think that
an evil empire like Japan during World
War two should have military control
over other territories and mistreated
civilians my friend doesn't believe that
we should kill anyone in war on the
opposing side but I disagree the topic
reminded me of the movie hacksaw Ridge
where the soldier during World War Two
was a conscientious objector and became
a medic but didn't kill anyone my
question is is it a sin to kill a
soldier from the opposing side of war
especially when they are part of an evil
regime I would say absolutely not the
the concept of just the Just War Theory
has been developed by Christians over
the over the centuries and the millennia
and it's been with rare exceptions of I
think you know hacks all Reds great
movie as well but in that case the I'm
blanking on his name but a real man a
hero though the movie was based around
but and he was I believe a Quaker I
think but so he was you know there have
been some small subdivisions of
Christianity that have been
conscientious objectors have been you
know
have-have believed that all violence is
wrong but the predominant thought
throughout christian history has been
that you know killing in self-defense is
perfectly morally justified and waging a
war as long as it's for just reasons and
I think that it would be very hard to
argue that World War two on the Allies
side was waged for unjust reasons
clearly waged not just to stop the mass
slaughter of innocent people but also to
stop this evil empire from taking it
from literally taking over the world so
I think that's pretty pretty clearly a
case of just killing now you lump the it
sounds like you're lumping the nuclear
strikes on Japan into that and that is
sort of a different sort of a different
topic entirely it's sort of it's a
different question you you could
certainly arrive at the conclusion that
you could certainly arrive at the
conclusion that it's perfectly justified
to wage war but then also arrive at the
conclusion that dropping a nuclear bomb
on a city and killing hundreds of
thousands of civilians is also wrong you
know those two things don't necessarily
go together all right
um let's see from Jason hi Matt I have a
very important question for you do you
listen to music if so I'd like to ask
what are your all-time favorite songs
I'd like to ask what your all-time
favorite songs are but I know that that
could be a hard question instead it is
our quiet because it changes for me I
mean you'd have to add changes by the
day really instead I'll be more specific
what are the five most recently played
songs on your iTunes playlist or Spotify
slash Pandora etc
first of all Jason I do listen to music
I am a human contrary to popular belief
what kind of human doesn't is there
anyone who doesn't listen to music just
doesn't like any kind of music at all
period I if there is that kind of human
I'm certainly not that now as most
recently played songs not most plates
what you want well I actually can answer
that because I was I was a over the
weekend I was driving I have kind of a
long drive through the country on Sunday
and as beautiful day and so I was
playing my driving through the country
on a Sunday playlist which we all have a
playlist right that so so I so most
recently played it would have been
Joleen by Ray LaMontagne great song
angel from Montgomery Old Crow Medicine
Show which is a cover of a John Prine I
believe young fathers by typhoon rising
water by James and Vincent McMorrow and
red eyes by the war on drugs so kind of
a weird collection no it doesn't that's
a that was my phone talking to me a
weird I think my phone heard me say the
war on drugs and said that doesn't sound
good my phone is a libertarian I guess
anyway a weird collection of songs but
you know it's it's that's I'm kind of a
weird guy I guess we'll leave it there
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed